okay thanks so I'm going to talk about
incentivizing exploration which is a
common model I'll describe to you what
that means a common model in the CS
literature and I'm going to focus on
solving it in a case with behavioral
agents that and and imposing that we use
what we're going to call unbiased
histories signals for these behavioral
agents and this is joint work with
teaming now who actually is now at
Facebook
Alex lyft khun's and Steven woo
so in this incentivized exploration
literature we have a sequence of agents
who are coming one by one to a system
and choosing an action that has some
unknown payoff so they're gonna get a
stochastic reward from some unknown
distribution and these decisions of the
agents are going to be coordinated by a
principal this could be like a
recommendation system for example that
is trying to suggest to the agents what
actions they might take and thereby what
rewards they might get applications so
we saw this a bit in Nikhil's talk
yesterday might be things like
you're trying to choose a restaurants in
a new city
so tourists come one by one they go to
Yelp they see what the recommendations
are on Yelp and then they pick a
restaurant and they get some payoff
based on the quality of the restaurant
which is as something stochastic and so
then Yelp would be the coordinating
principle trying to help the agents find
the best restaurants in aggregate over
the population you could have other
applications as well you might be buying
products and each product has some
quality and you're trying to be Amazon
or something like that and trying to
help the agents find the quad product of
high quality you could be choosing
medical treatments and here each medical
treatment might have a different health
outcome but importantly in this
literature and in the case I'm studying
today the payoff of a particular choice
is going to be a common value object so
everybody has the same value for or that
gets the same stochastic reward for the
action for a fixed action and so this is
related of course to the multi-armed
bandit literature this is basically the
multi-armed bandit problem if we don't
have agents muddying up the waters so
what are the multi-armed bandit problem
we have i'm going to be focusing on a
case of two arms throughout this talk
and so there's going to be the red
triangle arm and the blue diamond arm
and the multi-armed bandit algorithm is
going to sequentially pull one of these
two arms and receive a stochastic reward
I'm going to be focusing on a case in
which the reward is either 1 or 0 and
the important statistic then is the
probability with which a reward with
which a particular arm returns a reward
of 1 and so each arm is parameterized by
a coin which has some unknown bias and
the algorithm is going to pick an arm
and when it picks an arm what happens is
that coin of that unknown bias gets
flipped and the algorithm observes the
reward of the coin so the algorithm will
observe one if the coin flip came up
heads and 0 if it's tails but it doesn't
know the bias with which the coin was
flipped and so this is the multi-armed
bandit problem the algorithm gets to
decide how to pull these arms in order
to try and maximize the reward that it
receives over some fixed time horizon in
the incentivized exploration problem we
have a centralized planner and what the
centralized planner would like to do is
to always pull the arm with the highest
mean reward that would maximize the
expected or reward over time so we'd
like to tell every agent that comes into
the system if it knew them mean the best
product or the best arm the best option
it would tell every agent to pull that
arm every time and what we're going to
do in an abandoned algorithm so if we
didn't have incentives to worry about we
don't know which arm has the highest
mean reward so we're gonna try and pull
a sequence of arms that's going to
maximize what we call regret so I think
you know the not one thing that you
could try to optimize here that people
study is the expected reward in a
Bayesian setting but another thing which
is what I'm going to focus on in which
we focus on in the computer science case
is
algorithm
that maximize regret regret is going to
be defined as the optimal reward of the
algorithm is optimal reward which is the
highest mean reward times the time
horizon - the reward that the algorithm
is receives so we're trying to minimize
this rate of this difference okay and
one thing to note about this problem is
that for either of these objectives
because you don't know the mean rewards
of the arms any bandit algorithm that's
going to be doing well is going to have
to do both exploration and exploitation
so it's going to have to explore a bunch
to figure out which arms are the better
arms and then it's going to have to
leave itself enough time to exploit a
bunch in order to pull that arm with the
best reward so that it doesn't lose too
much compared to opt okay so now how do
we deal with the incentives
well the arms are going to be pulled in
our setting by agents based on signals
that they receive from the principal and
so what people have done is they say
okay let's have the principal commit to
a bi C signalling scheme so these agents
are going to be maximizing their you
know each agent that comes in is wants
to exploit for him or herself right so
they want to pull the arm that maximizes
their personal reward and the agent is
going to signal to them which which arm
that is the eight the principal would
like the agent to pull and if that
scheme so notice that there's a there's
an information asymmetry here because
the principal knows the outcomes of all
of the past arm pulls but the agent
comes into the system and doesn't have
that information and so the principal
can leverage this information asymmetry
to induce the agent to pull whichever
arm the principal wants on
some conditions on the signaling scheme
so there's some incentive constraints
the principal is going to commit to a
signalling scheme that's going to cause
the agents to want to follow the
recommendation of the principal and yeah
so there's it stands for Bayesian
incentive compatibility and the agent
that's coming into the system has some
information some prior over the mean
rewards and knows the signalling scheme
which so it knows the mapping from
whatever the principal knows to the
action and it has to be that when I do
my update on my prior and the out the
like output of the signalling scheme
given what I know about this mapping
that my best action is to follow the
recommendation and so you know then if
that's the case then the agents gonna
pull the recommended arm so the
principal can pick any signaling scheme
that induces this kind of behavior and
the objective is to pick one that's
going to minimize the regret yes the
agent knows their number and the signal
they receive yes and whatever prior they
have over the mean rewards with the arms
and so the question is how the principal
can induce exploration for the agents
yes why are you personally it is it's a
it's kind of like a dynamic version of
the Bayesian persuasion game for those
of you that know what that is
yeah there's a list related work there
so I think you're referring to this
paper so you know people have been
looking at this problem asking how we
can induce agents to explore and the top
two papers here the crime era months or
Perry and Mansoor Slifkin sir ganas are
going to induce explorations by
recommending that agents explore with
some small probability and then if like
you know you don't know if you're the
agent that I'm recommending that you
should explore maybe you were I was
actually telling you to exploit you
don't know which coin flip you got so
that's going to induce you to follow the
recommendation and the Frasier Kemp at
Kleinberg Kleinberg paper is going to
instead pay agents to explore and then
they get this very nice characterization
of the trade-off between explore exploit
based on how much we have to pay agents
to explore yes their priors based on
what they observe from their own choice
you have no observe they don't come
again
they come once they're tourists in a
city and the nice thing about this setup
is that the be IC schemes are going to
match the optimal learning algorithm
results so I that basically the
incentives don't hurt us at all in terms
of the objective we have in mind so we
can get the optimal regret even with
these centralized principles centralized
coordinated principles okay so this is
sort of the background this is what the
literature has been doing but sort of
the classic papers in this in this area
and here's the motivation that they have
in most of the introductions is the idea
that there's some web site like Yelp
Yelp has this problem that it doesn't
know the quality of the restaurants it
wants to give all of the users the best
experience possible wants them to go to
the best restaurants possible but it
doesn't know which ones are the best and
so it is going to make recommendations
and so here I was visiting Stanford
staying at the Sheraton which is like
kind of right here and I wanted to go
out for Chinese food and so I searched
for Chinese on Yelp and it gave me this
result and so what you can see is that
it sort it gives me first of all it
doesn't just tell me where to go as in
the setup that we've described so far it
instead gives me a list of options you
might think that and it doesn't you know
tell me and it doesn't just give me this
list with no explanation it tells me
something about each restaurant like the
rating that it seen so far the average
rating it seen so far and how many
reviews it has and so this is the the
list I got and and the thing is you
might think that this list is sorted
such that Yelp wanted me to go to taste
up there but you know looking at this I
see that garden-fresh has many more
reviews and a higher rating so maybe I
prefer to go to garden-fresh
and so I go there ignoring in the sense
the recommendation of the principle
which is to go to taste and so I want to
think about the disparities between the
standard incentivized exploration model
that I described and this app that we
all use frequently one thing is you know
when I was reasoning about where to go
did I think about a prior and do some
updating and about the signalling scheme
of Yelp and everything I just kind of
looked I was like oh it has more ratings
it has a higher start like a higher
average rating and decided to go there
so one question is do a gence really
perform full Bayesian updating or is
there something behavioral going on
about the agents and how does that
impact the
what the principal can achieve if they
if they aren't fully Bayesian updaters
another is this classic literature is
using sort of a revelation principle
style thing to say oh I can just tell
you where to go and you're gonna be
incentivized to follow that and it's all
fine and dandy but is it feasible in the
context of these applications to just
tell somebody where to go in particular
like you know if we had an app that just
said oh you want Chinese food go there
with no explanation I think we wouldn't
really trust it so they need to have
supporting evidence for the
recommendations they're making to us and
there's a bunch of other sort of
disparities between the classic model
and the reality that I'm not going to
focus on but I think are very
interesting we saw one yesterday which
is that restaurants can come and go over
time and so we and maybe the qualities
even drift over time and so we need to
han't manage that there's also the idea
that consumer search is costly and so I
can do some investigation to figure out
like I can go read all the reviews to
figure out what to get a more refined
signal and the quality of the restaurant
but that takes time and that's costly
agents could come in so somebody
mentioned this suici think like agents
could interact with a system repeatedly
that'll break a lot of these models and
then another thing that I've looked at a
bit is that we have this common value
assumption but what if agents are
inherently heterogeneous and their
preferences may be the diversity alone
induces enough exploration that we can
even just get rid of the coordinating
principle if if agents are diverse but
not too diverse you know like maybe oz
Arash likes Persian food better and so
but there is an overall best restaurant
so I'll go explore the Chinese food
she'll go explore the Persian food we'll
share information and we'll find the
best restaurant that way so these are
all like other directions that you see
in the literature that I think are also
very interests
but today I want to kind of address the
top two disparities here the rationality
assumption and the space of signalling
schemes that we permit so we're going to
look at a model in which the signals are
sub histories so you're the principal is
required to report the experiences of
some subset of agents and not just a
recommendation the agents themselves are
going to be frequentist so instead of
doing a Bayesian update the agents are
going to estimate the quality of a
restaurant using the empirical average
of the outcomes that they've seen in
these sub histories and in the you know
under these restrictions and behavioral
assumptions we're going to see that
there's a simple scheme that gets used
sublinear regret and then we will refine
this scheme to get a multi-layered
scheme that has near optimal regrets so
it matches the optimal regret bounds and
the sort of there's I think maybe three
main ideas in the proofs that can kind
of be like the most salient of which is
that there's this idea that we want a
group agents into focus groups which are
going to then explore different options
because of the stochasticity of the
setting and from that we can then learn
about each of these different options so
let me get into the results a little bit
more deeply so I will first define the
setting I'm going to focus as I said on
a setting with two arms and the arms are
going to have a mean reward MUA
I'm going to assume that it's well
really bounded away from zero but you
can think about it as being in the
interval one thirty two thirds and the
reward is going to be one with
probability mu sub a for arm a and zero
otherwise and I'll label the arms such
that arm one is the better arm okay so
mu 1 is larger than mu 2
the agents there's going to be some time
horizon capital T and agents are going
to be labeled by the time at which they
arrive to the system so we have a
sequence of agents a 1 a 2 up to a
capital T when the agent arrives they're
given a signal which is going to be one
of these histories of what's happened in
the past they might you might get
different histories if you arrive at
different time steps but you know that
up front and when you get your signal
you're going to choose some arm and then
you're gonna receive a reward based on
the mean or a word of that arm no I am
going to have signals are going to be a
subset of history so there's a subset of
time steps that I'm going to choose ex
ante up front and I'll discuss that on
an on a future slide but there's going
to be a subset of time steps and you are
going to see the arm that was pulled and
the reward of that arm for every time
step in that subset and that's what you
used to choose your yeah to optimize
your action and this can be differ for
agents that arrive at different time
steps yes our construction will
determine these subsets
deterministically I'm happy to let it be
randomized if but I want I'm jumping
ahead a little bit but I want the choice
of which history you see at a particular
time step to be chosen ex ante so I
don't want you to like the principal use
the history like use the realizations to
choose what history to give you so if
it's randomized flip all the coins in
the beginning
are what you have a village yeah it's a
so this is gonna depend on the
behavioral model of the agents I'm going
to like you can list all of them but
because of how I'm assuming agents
behave the average is going to be a
sufficient statistic and I'll discuss
that in a moment it was there another
question over here yeah last word about
knowing the signals is that the problem
definition or is that the policies
choice
I am restricting myself to consider
policies in this class so that the I am
not very clear and in the sense what are
the constraints on these subsets and so
on it could be anything any any policy
which up front decides at you know
Monday any agent that comes on Monday is
going to see the history of agents that
came over the weekend for example they
may see no history yeah
but they cannot be given a
recommendation and right
yes frequent decisions there's no
structure on the history some sort of
little nested structure and history DC
and the previous ones there will be a
structure on the history that's chosen
by the policy and the frequentist agents
are going to simply follow this
behavioral prescription which I'm going
the reason that I'm so insistent on
fixing the histories ex ante is to make
this seem like a reasonable behavior to
follow so because I'm fixing the
history's ex ante you know I'm not
trying to trick you into only seeing
histories where this outcome was good so
the frequentist yes yes the history does
so the frequentist agents are going to
look at a sub history they're gonna
count the number of poles of a
particular arm in that sub history so
that's on Yelp like the number of
reviews like Yelp has received for that
restaurant they're going to calculate
the empirical mean rewards and so to
Gabriel this question this is why it's
sufficient to just report the average
and then they're going to pick an
estimate of the reward of that arm which
I'm gonna so I'm gonna call empirical
mean rewards mu bar a the actual reward
mean reward is mu a and the estimates
that the agents form and this is their
behavioral choice is mu hat a and I'm
going to require that mu hat a gets
closer to MU bar a as the number of
samples grows so if you don't have very
many samples of the arm I'm letting you
do whatever you want but as you get more
and more samples of the arm you have to
get closer and closer to the empirical
mean reward and then they behavior that
they follow is they look at all their
estimates and they pick the arm with the
highest estimate and let's say that they
break ties randomly so notice that this
allows a whole class of behaviors like
I'm not
saying how they pick their new hat so
long as it's within this distance of the
empirical estimates they could even have
you know biases somebody might prefer
Chinese and somebody might prefer
Persian food so long as it's no you know
when once they get enough signals on the
other restaurant that they don't prefer
that then they then they might go there
right so long as they're close to the
empirical means at this point somebody
might ask what about Bayesian like
rational agents does this behavior
capture Bayesian rational agents that's
going to depend I think on the priors
that they have over the arms but I
prefer to think of these as behavioural
agents okay so now let's think about the
signals that we can use so I'm going to
require first of all the sub sister YZ
to be transitive and so all future
diagrams will assume that this but let's
suppose like why why do I care about
transitivity so what do I mean by
transitivity I mean that if I see what
facilities and vassilis sees you know
what azar sees then I also see what as
our seats if it weren't transitive then
I might worry that my behavioural agents
are like you know this guy if this is
not transitive is only seeing these is
maybe only seeing these two things and
doesn't know that this guy picked this
blue diamond option because he had a lot
of information about it and so I don't
like then and the behavioral assumption
starts to get a little sketchy like I
want I want to make sure that everybody
is working off of the same set of
information in the same back yes
this is consistent with Bayesian
estimate a strategic choice of the agent
or is it a deterministic function of the
history the pacing they get to pick
anything this can you know they have
some function that map's the history
they see to an estimate new hat as does
a Bayesian agent right I see but they're
not they're not picking that in a
strategic way based on some payoff
function it's just a good they are I
mean if they're fully Bayesian they're
gonna find some estimate of the mean
reward and they're gonna pick the thing
with the highest mean reward yes yes and
that's why that's why I said that like
for some priors and and maybe some
policies this might capture the Bayesian
but but like what what you have to check
is that does the Bayesian agents the the
posteriors mean reward actually fall in
this interval of the empirical mean
reward if it does then fine Bayesian
agents are fine just the principal have
access to how they pour that where does
food are all we know is that it's a
statically this is all they need to know
okay so I also as we've been discussing
want to make sure that we're choosing
the sub history that the agencies
ex-ante because otherwise the principal
can basically only show you reviews
where this restaurant was highly rated
and then you have to start reasoning
about why it is the principal you know
why is this restaurant look so good
maybe it's because the principal's
policy was to only show me reviews where
that restaurant was highly rated but if
you choose the signalling scheme if you
choose the sub history ex-ante the
principal can't fool you in this way
they're committing upfront before they
see the outcomes of the agents that came
on those particular days
okay so this is the restriction I'm
going to impose on the signalling space
and so now the principle is supposed to
choose signaling schemes that are going
to minimize regret given the behavioral
model of agents so again the regret is
what the opto sees by pulling the better
arm every day the best arm every day -
what the principle receives so in time
horizon T the optimal algorithm is going
to get an expected reward of team you
won because mu 1 recalls the better arm
and the agent is going to get I mean the
principal is going to get the
expectation of the sum over all the
agents of the mean reward of the arm
that that agent pulled and so that's the
optimal utility and this is the utility
that the that the population enjoys when
following wait you know under the
existence of this principle and I want
this to be minimized in worst case over
the realization of the mean rewards
so over our worst case choice further
amine rewards of the arms because in
some sense for people what can
understand with there are risk averse
but for some principle it's not clear
that so well so like I just want to
think about somebody is picking these
like an adversary is picking these mean
rewards and then the principle is trying
to minimize this in the worst case over
what that you know adversary is doing
and like you know you're probably
preferring to come from some economics
approach where you have some
distribution over mean rewards and like
you're trying to optimize the expected
utility of the agents in a Bayesian
sense so that's not what we're doing
we're trying to do a worst-case thing
and minimize this difference we can talk
more about the choice of these two
objectives offline but this is the
standard one that we use in computer
science I think it's been inherited from
that literature okay so a first attempt
would be to let everybody see everything
that seems natural what's gonna happen
if I let everybody see everything so
some that we might have two arms one
which is a bit better than the other but
the better arm is going to get a bunch
of bad outcomes in the full history it's
just by chance the first few times
somebody went to that restaurant they
hated it and so as a result the
empirical mean is going to drop and the
of the better restaurant and the other
restaurant is going to have a high
empirical mean now as soon as these
empirical means separate by enough
you're gonna get the error bars that I'm
allowing based on the number of times
the arm has been pulled are gonna
suddenly separate and now even if agents
behavioral choices are super optimistic
about the red triangle and pessimistic
about the dime
and they nonetheless are going to assume
that the diamond is better than the
triangle and they're after everybody's
gonna go to the diamond we're never
gonna update about the triangle and
essentially we've heard it it was a
slightly different from the hurting
literature in economics but it's kind of
like we've heard it on this suboptimal
option and so that doesn't work there's
these you just get you can show that you
just need a constant number of bad draws
to have this separation occur and so we
get a constant probability that we end
up all pulling the suboptimal arm and
then we're gonna have linear regret
alright so the other thing that's pretty
natural is to have no history at first
and so for this setting let's suppose
that we know the gap
let's first imagine that we know the gap
between the reward of the best arm and
the second-best arm and in that case I'm
going and let's say that with no
information and agents are going to
choose an arm at random this is just
kind of for convenience we'll see that
we don't actually need that in the
policy we really design but let now
let's imagine no history at first this
is a policy which is going to have some
number K of K agents appear in the
system and then thereafter it's and with
no history at all so nobody's these guys
don't get any history and then
thereafter everybody sees outcomes of
those K agents only what's that going to
do there's this theorem and statistics
this is okay I have to biased coins can
i distinguish which one's the better
coin and so it's not hard to calculate
that you can distinguish bias coins with
high probability using a low number of
samples which scales like 1 over Delta
squared when the gap between the bias of
the coins is Delta and so using that
theorem we can calculate the regret that
you would get from this example and all
I think this is all sort of very
standard stuff in computer
I just want to do it so you see what the
proof looks like so you set you you
notice that the optimal plan is going to
get as we've said T times mu1 the mean
reward of the better arm the plan with
no history is going to get K mu - that's
these first K agents in are getting at
least the Year award of the worse arm
which is Mewtwo and the remaining t
minus K agents well if this event
happened that the coins were
distinguished then they're going to pull
the better one because the gap is large
enough that and they've seen enough
samples that they're even there
estimates are going to cause them to
pull the better one and in the event
that the coins weren't distinguished we
can't say anything so let's say they get
you two now you take the difference of
these two things and you get something
that's if you set K appropriately is
like log T over delta so this is the
regret of no history but notice that it
required us to know Delta the gaps in
the arms in order to decide how many
agents to give no history to and so we
can improve like you know we can avoid
no needing to know this with simple
algorithms and this is you know
following what you would expect if you
know the multi-armed bandit literature
we can get a regret of T to the 2/3 and
I'm hiding this tilde here means I'm
hiding log factors you know what I'm
gonna call a two level policy I can get
improved regret if I add one extra layer
to my policy and then with another trick
I can get a multi layer policy that gets
near optimal regret so as K grows this
approaches one half and notice that with
non adaptive policies and multi-armed
bandit
total regret is T to the 2/3 which is
what I'm getting with my to level policy
and in adaptive policies and multi armed
bandits get regret like T to the 1 half
which is what I'm getting basically with
my multi-layer policy yes you can
distinguish their arms but you're
thinking the worst gives over the
transom and I'm not really sure how to
fit those two things together oh you
still like me is just setting the
submissions yeah yeah the initial phase
when you don't show me decedent's are
just picking something at random that's
what I'm assuming for that analysis it's
basically so to get rid of so I'm in my
two levels I'm going to basically just
blow up those guys that are picking
something at random it's large enough
that even if they're picking something
deterministically like if they always
favor armed to then there's enough
samples of arm to that it drops below
arm 1 and then they if you're happy to
put there for them to pick something
random then that is the two level policy
if you're not then you can do this thing
where they're going to eventually figure
it out that the other arm like they're
gonna like the bat the each arm is going
to get unlucky and get enough bad draws
that they're going to be induced to pull
the other arm no matter how they're
picking their estimates
okay so so that's how we get to level
two we create a level one where each we
have a bunch of different groups and in
each group we have this full history
policy that we saw earlier which might
with constant probability causes agents
to herd on one of the two arms and so as
a result each of these groups is going
to like each arm is going to be sampled
a enough times with constant probability
and then in we're going to add this
level to on top in which they see all of
the outcomes of the level ones and hence
they see many samples of each arm and so
this two level thing is going to get
regret or which is order T to the 2/3
and again the intuition here is that
level e one agents are providing enough
exploration to distinguish the better
arm if the gap is large and if the gap
is not large then we're not incurring
that much regret by not learning which
arm is the better arm and so it takes a
little bit of calculation it's pretty
standard calculation I'm not going to go
through it but I we have this first we
have to prove that that in the level one
we get an order K Omega of K samples of
each arm with high probability where K
is the number of groups like paths that
I've constructed and by concentration
bounds we can show that the empirical
mean and the first tile poles of any arm
is concentrated around its true mean and
therefore because of the agents are
picking stuff close to the empirical
mean each arm is going to get sampled
and then if the gap is large enough the
level two agents are going to pull the
best arm and you get T to the 2/3 so I'm
not going to go through this it's just a
lot of notation and it's very standard
in the multi-armed bandit literature
when you want to prove T to the 2/3 and
why are we getting 2/3 here it's because
essentially the level 1 agents are
exploring
for us and then the level two agents are
exploiting the explorations of the level
one agents and explore then exploit
algorithms so we're just mimicking and
explore then exploit I'll grow them and
they are known to get T to the 2/3
regret and in to improve on this regret
we have to implement adaptive
explorations so the question is how can
we use these sub histories to induce an
adaptive exploration among agents and
the idea is to leverage the cases in
which the level 2 makes a mistake in
which the gap wasn't large enough and
level 2 might actually try to pick the
wrong arm and so I'm gonna make many
copies of level 2 and in each of these
copies you know either the gap is large
and so these guys are doing enough
exploration for everybody above them or
the gap isn't large enough in which case
these guys some of them are going to be
picking the suboptimal arm and hence
they're going to do the exploration
required for level 3 so here the
adaptivity is on was the gap large
enough or not
so - yeah the analysis is going to have
it's going to be a case analysis based
on the size of the gap but the policy is
just going to explore down here it's
going to exploit up there and the middle
level is going to explore if there's a
clear winner among these levels you know
in each of these levels and if there
isn't a clear winner in each of these
levels then it's going to induce this
level to do more exploration and so this
is how we get the added apptivity and so
if I set the parameters correctly I can
get Z to the 4/7 as before you know the
proof is going to condition on good
events one is that level one explores
enough to is that there's concentration
in the prefixes so that I get
concentration around the of the
empirical mean around the true mean and
then there's going to be this event that
there's anti concentration in level one
so in each level one group there's some
group where each arm looks good and the
other arm looks bad compared to the true
mean inducing more exploration so as I
said the proof is based on this case
analysis of the gap between the two arms
and if the gap is negligible I don't
care I'm gonna get a good regret no
matter what if the gap is large that's
the case we were in before level one did
enough exploration to determine which
was the better arm and then level two
and three agents exploit they're out
there but what we need to do to improve
the T to the 2/3 is solve these
intermediate gap cases so if the gap is
medium then maybe level two is making
some mistakes but because they only see
one of the groups of level one but in
aggregate overall of the level one
groups the level three agents are able
to identify the better arm so we just
like lose on level two but level three
has enough information to exploit and
then the interesting case here is
there's if you do the calculations
you'll see there's still a gap between
what we can
allow here to get our regret bound and
the negligible gap where we don't care
anymore
so we call that a small gap case and so
for the small gap case we're going to
need this anti concentration bound where
in each of the groups like level one
groups that a level two collection of
people observes there's some probability
that they're making a mistake in each
direction and that's what's going to
induce the extra exploration so we use
this anti concentration bound to argue
that there's this extra exploration in
this level to group and now the level
three agents are gonna pull the correct
arm not because they see all of level
one but because they see all of level
two and the level twos have been induced
to explore because the gap wasn't
separated enough so that gets us this
improved bound and if you do like
there's a lot of things you have to
balance you're going to get T to the
four sevenths but as I mentioned you
would like to get T to the one-half and
again the reason that we're not getting
T to the one-half is because we need you
know we can handle a large gap medium
gap small gap and negligible but we need
to subdivide this more we need to do
this again and again so for any
particular gap that's between the mean
rewards there's going to be some level
that we want to be the one that does the
exploration for the levels above it and
so we can try to create that
construction by just repeating what we
saw before now we can have these big
group you know this this three level
thing we can replicate it many times and
then put four level agents above it and
now you know the three level agents in
the like smaller than small gap but
larger the negligible gap case are gonna
make some mistakes inducing exploration
at this level which lets the level four
agents do the right thing but of course
the problem with this construction is
that I've blown up the number of agents
in level one and recall
these guys are getting bad regret
because they in you know could be
pulling the bad arm with constant
probability so I want to get a more like
compressed version of this construction
and so the idea is to reuse information
so this is being very wasteful about the
information that these guys are
collecting and so I can create a
condensed version of this construction
that reuses information I don't have
time to go into how that happens exactly
but the idea is that if I set up the sub
histories correctly then in this
remember this level L minus one is
trying to explore the you know each each
arm gets explored by the L minus one
level in some groups and then the guys
above it are like maybe in these groups
the triangle got lucky so these guys are
gonna do more triangle exploration for
me and in these groups the diamond got
lucky so these guys are going to do more
diamond exploration for me and notice
that the histories that the red outlined
people see is disjoint from the
histories that the blue outlined people
see which is what allows me to argue
that these middle layer here is going to
be exploring and then we get in the top
layer they get to see explorations of
both types of arms and hence they can
exploit and so that that's the history
they see they exploit and that allows me
to get improved regret bounce so I can
go all the way down to approaching t to
the 1/2 so in conclusion I get optimal
regret by revealing sub histories in a
model with behavioral agents the
two-level idea was to use focus groups
the three level idea let us improve our
regret bound by adding group aggregators
that helped us refine the explore
and the L level got us is a way that you
can reuse exploration in order to
improve the regret found even further
thank you question if there is one
so this is create a different problem of
different people seeing different
ratings so yes and I are both looking at
Yelp and I see three standard East Coast
and yes this definitely happens in this
policy because like if you belong to
different focus groups some are might
get lucky and some where might get
unlucky so we need you to do these
decisions independently but yeah that
will happen okay thank you very much we
are going to take a 25-minute break
rather than a 30-minute break and we'll
resume